quisiera preguntarle por supuesto en
primer lugar quién era y brian al
quraishi
muchas gracias por la invitación en
santiago al cura si era actualmente el
jefe de isis un terrorista fundamentado
en las líneas extremistas del salafismo
he capacitado en su formación tanto
religiosa como organizativa para dirigir
a estas estructuras en la antigua
mesopotamia y con las extensiones que
tiene el grupo terrorista en diversos
puntos del planeta en especial con mucho
contacto con las organizaciones o las
células que tienen en afganistán y
pakistán que llaman escuras and también
con la facilidad de diseminar a sus
contactos en otras partes del mundo para
entrenar lo que llaman los lobos
solitarios y los imanes que los entrenan
y los forman como extremistas del
yihadismo
ahora hay que tanto golpea esto al
estado islámico qué consecuencias reales
podría tener esto para el grupo
pues para el grupo para la geopolítica
porque en la región hay un caldero
geopolítico en ebullición permanente y
favorece la muerte de este señor a todos
los enemigos que tenía el estado
islámico pero a la vez también los pone
a todos en la mira y en la evolución que
es lo que usted me pregunta y lo más
complicado de pensar que puede pasar es
que la reacción la retaliación vendrá y
en la proporción que esté en las células
en diferentes partes del mundo tendremos
muchas posibilidades de que en occidente
haya venganzas fuertes porque ya es el
segundo cabecilla de dices que muere en
menos de tres años y en una forma muy
parecida
entonces la retaliación va a ser fuerte
en occidente y en los países donde y si
se estaba buscando posicionarse como el
elemento dinamizador de la política
yihadista en el mundo